die erste große flut bilanz der
regierung und offenbar sind bund und
länder trotz versagens und katastrophal
ab an mit ihrer arbeit sehr zufrieden
vor allem ein satz in dem papier das
bild vorliegt von innen und
finanzministerium macht wirklich
sprachlos auf seite 10 heißt es das
system des bevölkerungsschutzes mit der
klaren kommunalen verantwortung und der
auf wachsenden unterstützung durch
landkreise länder und den bund hat sich
in dieser lang anhaltenden hochwasser
lage grundsätzlich als trag- und
leistungsfähig
und das sonst system des
bevölkerungsschutzes hat sich
grundsätzlich als trat uns
leistungsfähig erwiesen
das stimmt also absolut nicht es war
also katastrophal es war wirklich ohne
irgendwie vorher eine verständigung zu
bekommen von unserem lieben herr landrat
dem herrn köhler also da war gar nichts
hätte ich eine vorwarnung gehabt dann
hätte ich vieles retten können wie viele
andere menschen natürlich auch und wenn
ich dann einsatz lese wie das system des
bevölkerungsschutzes hat sich
grundsätzlich als trag- und
leistungsfähig erwiesen dann ist das
eine realitätsferne absolut habe ich
finde tiere die katastrophenschutzschule
des bundes ist hier in bad neuenahr
ahrweiler zu hause die ausbildung der
ausbilder sind hier tätig und was ist
passiert
zur warnung oder zum katastrophenschutz
sehr wenig muss ich feststellen dass ist
nach und nach sich verbessert hat das
ist klar aber die erste woche waren wir
ziemlich allein gelassen oder haben wir
sehr gute helfer werden wir hier wird
das hier nicht so sehen also mit anderen
worten es gibt auch meiner frau völlig
recht ich glaube das hätte alles ein
bisschen früher passieren müssen und
es ist eigentlich noch schleppend
sogar der krisenstab weil die erste zeit
in der laaer und hatte etwa die
unternehmen fremde leute kamen aus ganz
deutschland haben nie ob im schlamm
geschäft und er sagte der krisenstab
eine woche später oder thw wie sie alle
heißen keine ahnung wie wir an auf sowas
nicht auf so eine flut nicht vorbereitet
war das normale volk auf so eine flucht
vorbereitet war ich mir dann doch nicht
normal zu warten das ist also
unverständnis natürlich in bad
neuenahr-ahrweiler wo bild ja auch sein
blut büro eingerichtet hat schäfer wir
hatten am freitag hier exklusiv in der
sendung das papier bekommen da gibt es
mehrere punkte wo sich die regierung
selber auf die schulter klopft ich
glaube der punkt den wir aber gerade
gesehen haben das ist der entscheidende
also das papier 20 seiten aus dem
bundesfinanzministerium und dem
bundesinnenministerium also von olaf
scholz und von horst seehofer listet auf
was alles schiefgelaufen ist bzw listet
die schäden auf sagt auch wie viele
menschen zu tode gekommen sind aber dann
dieser bemerkenswerte wirklich fast
höhnisch satz muss man so oder verhöhnen
der satz dass im großen ganzen doch
alles ziemlich gut gelaufen ist und dass
die sicherungssysteme funktioniert haben
das gegenteil ist der fall wir haben es
auch gerade nochmal beitrag gesehen das
gegenteil ist der fall und interessant
ist dass zb armin laschet der
regierungschef auch in nordrhein
westfalen ist jetzt auch ein
gegengutachten in auftrag gegeben hat
weil er eben auch sagt dieser bericht
der bundesregierung der stimmt einfach
mit der realität nicht überein
sein bericht so wird gemutmaßt dürfte
deutlich kritischer ausfallen hat den
ehemaligen thw chef bringe damit
beauftragt diesen bericht zu erstellen
wird mutmasslich erst nach der
bundestagswahl fertig aber das wird
mutmasslich ein bericht werden der
deutlich realistischer die probleme
einschätzt und dann auch aufzeigen soll
was man ändern muss künftig im
katastrophenschutz damit sich so etwas
wie wir es gesehen haben im juli nicht
wiederholt es gibt viel kritik zu recht
natürlich haben die verantwortlichen
denn auch irgendwas gut gemacht
es fällt immer schwer wenn man die
bilder sieht
und auch die geschichten dazu hört zu
glauben und zu sagen dass etwas gut
gelaufen ist natürlich der einsatz der
thw kräfte die wir gesehen haben der
bundespolizei und auch von soldaten hat
natürlich dazu beigetragen dass not auch
gelindert werden konnte ganz klar da
wurde beim aufräumen geholfen da wurden
auch notstromaggregate gesetz der wurde
viel gemacht um die situation der
menschen ein bisschen zu verbessern aber
es reicht ja oft nicht wenn wir jetzt
von von bewohnern der betroffenen
landkreise hören dass sie zum teil gar
nicht wissen wie sie strom mäßig über
den winter kommen sollen weil dort erst
im februar oder märz ein anschluss ans
stromnetz oder auch an die versorgung
mit elektrizität und energie wieder
gesichert werden kann er dann müssen
diese menschen ihren häusern im winter
frieren also was soll man diesen
menschen denn sagen was bisher gut
gelaufen ist auch die auszahlung die 30
milliarden die der bund bereitgestellt
hat das geld kommt tröpfchenweise dort
an die bürokratie ist wieder extrem also
ordnungsämter beschweren sich und
bestrafen menschen die hab und gut dass
jetzt nicht mehr benutzbar ist vor ihrer
häuser stellt ja wo sollen sie denn
sonst hinstellen wenn nicht dort hin das
ist dann aber nicht richtig angemeldet
gewesen also das buch hat schon wieder
die bürokratie macht es den menschen
extrem schwer an einen tüchtigen und in
dem fall auch helfen den staat zu
glauben
[Musik]